It was November 20th, 2019, and the helicopter
circled far above in the freezing wind of
the Antarctic.
SCP Foundation Site Director Jason Monroe
looked down at the isolated
above-ground facilities
of Provisional Site-344-1.
Something about this place made him nervous.
Edgy.
And for good reason: Between 2003 and 2019,
twenty-nine Mobile Task
Force units and seventy-three
members of D-Class personnel had gone missing
here and never been found.
Monroe thought he was here
for a routine investigation
into negligence and mismanagement, but little
did he know, he was in for so much more.
This is the story of SCP - 5545, and one man’s
journey into his own worst nightmare.
Literally.
But this nightmare began a long time ago - 300
years, to be exact.
And like most nightmares, it started as a
dream.
That dream was one of expansion - national
powers across Europe wanted to be the first
to conquer the globe and
expand into new territories,
and sent countless exploratory missions off
into the unknown to achieve this goal.
Any history book will tell you that the first
outsiders to lay eyes upon the continent of
Antarctica did so in 1820 - the reality is
that the first ones to get there actually
landed in the late 1700s.
The hapless explorers ventured into mainland
Antarctica and made base camps, before searching
and digging for any useful resources nearby.
They came upon a strange discovery: A hallway,
hidden beneath the ice.
Not a passage in the ice, but a true hallway
- complete with light fixtures.
The confused explorers ventured down into
these impossible hallways, and for many of
them, it would be the last thing they ever
did.
No matter how long they walked, it seemed
like the hallways just kept going.
As they continued to walk for hours, they
hoped they’d find something… anything.
And eventually, they did.
They passed from these hallways into somewhere
different altogether, and most of them were
never heard from again.
Those who did manage to escape often died
or took their own lives soon after.
Whatever it was they’d discovered down there,
they didn’t want to live with it on their
minds.
It’s believed that over seventy colonial
explorers disappeared or died this way and
that most who found these endless hallways
beneath the Antarctic ice never returned.
The multiple anomalous objects and phenomena
that make up SCP-5545 came into the Foundation’s
hands several centuries later on September
18th, 2003, when during an expedition into
the Antarctic, they too found the endless
hallways.
The Foundation built Provisional Site-344-1
around them, hoping to safely seal them off
from any other unwitting Antarctic explorers
or researchers.
But there was something else lurking beneath
the ice in Antarctica.
Something dangerous.
The hallways were designated as SCP - 5545
- 1 and were thought to be the extent of the
anomalous activity at the site, but soon SCP
- 5545 - 2 was discovered, which resulted
in the deaths of sixteen researchers.
So what exactly is 5545 - 2?
It’s an entity so volatile that even knowing
about it is considered to be a containment
breach, and - as a result - it’s kept in
Provisional Site-344-2.
Unlike Site - 344 - 1, 344 - 2 isn’t a physical
space.
It’s conceptual, accessible only through
the endless hallways, created with the express
purpose of keeping 5545 - 1 and 5545 - 2 separate.
Why?
Because whenever the two come into contact,
the result is 5545 - 3: The network of endless
hallways expanding.
If they remained in contact, the hallways
would continue to expand and the entire planet
could be filled with endless hallways in just
four to six hours.
While the two are apart though, 5545 - 3 reverses,
but it always would take just a few hours
to throw the whole world into a chaos of infinite
hallways.
SCP-5545 has been given the classification
“Safe”…
Wait, we’re dealing with a mysterious and
volatile anomaly that’s claimed a huge number
of lives and still somehow eludes true Foundation
understanding, yet the official SCP Foundation
classification is “Safe?”
How could this be?
Monroe was the Director of Site - 58, and
was the definition of no-nonsense.
Prior to taking the Site Director position,
he was a decorated member of Mobile Task Force
Eta-10 and helped contain numerous Keter-Class
anomalies.
He’d been around the proverbial block when
it came to anomalous activity, and something
about SCP - 5545, and the
management of Provisional
Site 344, seemed awfully suspicious to him.
And he had questions.
Like how such an unpredictable anomaly could
be declared “safe”?
And why had there been such
a lapse of communication
between the Foundation and Doctor Gabriel
Reed, who’d been running the facility for
the past two decades?
And most of all, just what exactly was the
mysterious SCP - 5545 - 2?
Monroe started to believe that something terrible
had happened at the site, and Reed was covering
it all up.
But to find out for sure, he’d need to go
to Antarctica and investigate it himself.
Information around this supposedly “Safe”
anomaly was highly classified - those without
O5 clearance could face termination for snooping.
But that didn’t scare Jason Monroe.
He’d dealt with Keters before, he could
deal with this.
Or so he thought.
Monroe submitted a request and was granted
unanimous approval by the O5 Council to travel
to Provisional Site 344 and get to the bottom
of this mystery.
He took a chopper to the base soon after,
armed with a concealed firearm and a Hostile
Meme Detector - or HMD - to test whether the
base and its staff had somehow fallen under
a hazardous memetic effect from SCP - 5545.
He’d find the answers, or die trying.
The moment Monroe arrived, he couldn’t help
but notice the strange way the staff behaved.
They seemed listless; almost depressive.
When he showed his credentials to a researcher,
they simply said “SCP-5545-2 is contained
in Site-344-2.”
His request to see Dr. Reed that night was
denied.
Dr. Reed was busy, he was told.
Wait until tomorrow.
The next day, Monroe met with Dr. Reed, but
the results of the meeting were underwhelming
to say the least.
Just like the rest of the staff on the site,
he seemed exhausted, as though he hadn’t
slept in days.
His responses were quiet and evasive, and
he refused to tell Monroe anything that wasn’t
in the official files already.
Monroe ran the conversation through the HMD
and found nothing out of the ordinary.
What was going on here?
Monroe was irritated, but not deterred.
Nothing would stop him from finding out the
truth.
The next day, he flexed his O5 credentials
and hacked into the base’s security system.
This gave him access to cameras around Site
- 344 -1, but more importantly, there was
a single camera inside the mysterious Site
- 344 - 2.
Jackpot.
But when he looked at it, the feed was an
entirely black screen with the words “SCP-5545-2
is contained in Site-344-2.”
The footage of the staff in 344 - 1 was equally
strange: The eighteen employees on site all
sat at computer banks, with nothing but static
playing on their screens.
Monroe kept digging though, and was able to
hack into the security footage of Dr. Reed’s
office.
As he watched, he discovered a fifteen minute
period where Reed left the office each day.
He could use this brief window to break in
and collect more intel on SCP - 5545 - 2.
Monroe was so wrapped up in the investigation
that he almost forgot the more immediate danger
around him, and nearly wandered into one of
the endless hallways of 5545 - 1 by mistake.
He made a note to be more careful in future...
His first attempt at breaking into Dr. Reed’s
office didn’t produce many answers - one
piece of evidence was a blurry picture of
what looked like a Mobile Task Force entering
a 5545 - 1 hallway in the dark.
Another was a spreadsheet featuring all the
personnel, living or dead, who’d worked
at the site - but one name, and the details
of whether this person was alive or dead,
was completely redacted.
Anything particularly juicy was hidden behind
O5 clearance.
If Monroe wanted the answers, he’d need
to break through.
That night, he had a horrific recurring nightmare,
one that had plagued him since he joined MTF
Eta-10.
He dreamed he was in a fancy dining room with
a grand fireplace.
The room was full of statues of men and women.
The men looked angry, and the women looked
afraid.
As he approached the fireplace, the ceiling
extended infinitely up into the darkness.
Suddenly, the zombie-like body of a teenage
girl appears in the fireplace, hanging from
a long thread.
Her eyes look furious and full of rage, and
Monroe somehow knows that he’s the reason
for her hate.
When he steps into the fireplace in this dream,
she attacks him, the two intertwine, and they
burn forever.
The one difference was that in this new iteration
of the dream, he blinked upon entering the
fireplace, and suddenly, he was in a hallway.
He awoke sure that something was terribly
wrong here, but he couldn’t give up now.
The next day, Monroe broke into Dr. Reed’s
office and made a horrifying discovery.
He found files indicating that Dr. Reed was
knowingly sending Mobile Task Forces and D-Class
personnel into the infinite hallways of 5545
- 1 to their doom.
He also found evidence that
Reed and the researchers
had been spying on him, somehow intercepting
copies of the notes he had been taking.
That’s when Dr. Reed entered the office
and interrupted him.
Monroe panicked and drew his weapon, holding
the doctor at gunpoint.
He was breaking so many Foundation rules,
but right now, he feared for his life.
The doctor seemed unbothered by Monroe’s
threats though.
He told Monroe that everything was going to
plan, and that he should go back to his room.
Monroe was becoming increasingly paranoid
- he felt that, at any moment, guards might
burst in and execute him.
Nothing about this place made sense.
He worried he was going insane.
Perhaps the only way to find answers was to
go even deeper: To risk it all, and venture
through the endless hallways to find SCP - 5545
- 2 himself, and finally discover what this
thing actually was.
Monroe left his room and stepped into one
of the endless hallways of 5545 - 1 that was
located just across from his dorm.
He found that it was a hallway like all the
others on site - Plain concrete, worn with
age, with simple light fixtures on the walls.
He walked for hours, recording with a concealed
device.
The lights suddenly went out, leaving him
in complete darkness.
When they flicked back on, he was in a very
different environment: A grand, old carpeted
hallway, the kind you’d see in an old mansion.
He broke into a cold sweat.
What was so familiar about this place?He kept
walking, wracked with terror, until this new
hallway finally led him to the place he’d
been seeking: Site 344 - 2, the domain of
5545 - 2.
It was a large, poorly-lit room, filled with
grimacing statues and a large fireplace at
the far end.
It was the exact same room from Monroe’s
dream - with one horrifying difference.
Monroe noticed a single white thread hanging
down from the infinite ceiling, and when he
looked up to find its source, he screamed.
There were hundreds of bodies hanging and
swinging from the ceiling above him - everyone
who SCP - 5545 - 2 had ever killed, including
MTF members, D-Class Personnel, and even the
colonial explorers from hundreds of years
before.
And all of them were him.
Every single one.
They had his face.
And there, hanging in the middle of the room
at ground level, was the body of a teenage
girl, the one from his dream.
In that moment, he finally recognized her:
She was the girl he killed.
The first him.
Hundreds of years ago.
Much like Monroe, you’re probably wondering:
What is going on here?
Thanks to declassified communications between
Dr. Reed and the O5 Council, we can tell you.
Jason Monroe is a man who’s been reincarnated
hundreds of times over the last three hundred
years, ever since he murdered a teenage girl…
A girl named Emily… his daughter.
This murder sparked the existence of SCP - 5545
as an eternally recurring punishment for his
crimes.
Since figuring this out, the Foundation has
kept tabs on Monroe’s reincarnations - whether
they’re MTF members, D-Class personnel,
or even Site Directors.
They see to it that these reincarnations always
find their way back to 5545 - 2 to take his
punishment, and prevent the infinite hallway
expansion that threatens to destroy the world.
It’s a plan everyone is in on - everyone
except him.
But every time he enters that nightmare-haunting
room, it all comes rushing back.
In that moment though, he knew his crime,
and he somehow knew how many times this punishment
had unfolded for him.
He now had two choices: Repent and accept
the punishment again, or leave and activate
5545 - 3, potentially allowing the endless
tunnels to expand across the world.
Like his many predecessors, Monroe made the
decent choice.
He accepted his punishment and allowed his
own string to coil around him as the lights
in the room went off, one by one, leaving
only darkness.
Jason Monroe - that version of him, at least
- was never seen again.
But The SCP Foundation is already eyeing up
his next reincarnation, and preparing to let
this twisted cycle play out all over again.
And while you’re here, why not check out
“SCP - 066 - Eric’s Toy” and “SCP
- 035 - The Possessive Mask” for more mysterious
anomalies from the SCP Foundation!